Kevon almost 600 million bucks for two
apps apps that don't make any money yet
are you jumping the shark brother what
are you doing first of all we think
there's an enormous opportunity in
wearables in general the energy around
it is something that is as big as we've
seen coming fresh back off of CES you
just see the amount of energy and
excitement around it but the one thing
we noticed is that no one is around
community the investment community we
started this journey of making these
acquisitions more than a year ago with
the acquisition of MapMyFitness in
december 2013 and what we learned with
the leadership of Robin Thurston and our
team there was that the things that we
loved was the community the things that
we didn't have was we didn't have
nutrition and we didn't have a global
perspective so by buying endomondo based
in Copenhagen by buying My Fitness Pal
based in San Francisco gives us an
anchor in San Francisco gives us an
anchor in Europe Lloyd that Pan global
view as well as we can aggregate the
largest the world's largest digital
fitness and health community in
absolutely BarNone 120 million
registered users how does that translate
into you selling product right so the
thing that we looked at is is the one
thing that we know is the more that
someone exercises the more that they
workout the more the more athletic
apparel the more athletic footwear
they're gonna buy last month alone we
had over 100 million workouts logged
into one of our four applications
between My Fitness Pal and don't mind o
mat my fitness and UA record which we
launched last week at last month at CES
but no one's paying to log those no
one's making a money
look there's what we we want people to
be understanding is that we want to
drive value so monetization everybody
says it look there's a there's a
advertising model these guys have in
place right now whether that's the right
place for them to be or not we don't
know what it is yet so I don't think
advertisers gonna be placed for Drive
there's a subscription model that's
available there's the ability for us
just to push content last year we had a
ad with with misty Copeland and Gisele
we had 13 million YouTube views and it
was extraordinary the reaction I think
what it did for a woman's business we
have hundred and twenty million
registered users 72 million of which are
women the ability for us to push content
in the right way to speak to the athlete
and again the more that they exercise
but we know who is exercising because
they're voluntarily giving us this data
to help make them better seven sighs
that make it easier if that's what we do
does that
you were becoming a media / content
company like what GoPro wants to do I
you know look our goal with all these
acquisitions was to sell more shirts and
shoes that is our core business and so
everything we do must come back to the
core so ultimately we think that if we
can help athletes help help humans help
everyone find ways and make it easy for
them to understand the information
they're doing and attract their progress
of how they're getting better we think
that they're gonna buy ultimately more
shirts than shoes then are you getting
out of the team sport business and into
this health wellness lifestyle yeah no
but I think it's we're never gonna
depart sports so everything we do when
we think about record and again our five
growth drivers since we went public in
2005 men's apparel women's apparel
footwear international direct consumer
so right now it hits on all five of our
growth drivers so for men you know
there's a 16 year old high school
linebacker right now who's measuring
himself in the door jamb of their height
of their bedroom and saying did I get an
inch taller this year or not to have
quantifiable data about making that
athlete better for women's as I
mentioned the 77 million women that we
have on the app right now for our
footwear business there are people that
log into MapMyFitness
and they're tracking their Footwear as
to how many miles they put the duration
of the shoe they have our international
business we have 52 million people
outside of North America that now have
their first handshake with Under
Armour's going to be in this digital
capacity are you changing your strategy
the last time you and I spoke you had
just missed out on Kevin Durant that was
a 300 million dollar price tag now you
spent 560 it was this a better move do
you not want to pay for athletes anymore
Stephanie we're constantly changing our
strategy we're constantly updating what
we're doing but we have core principles
that drive the things that make us money
selling more shirts and shoes we viewed
this was the ability for us to sell a
lot more shirts and shoes and more
importantly to make athletes better
there's this white space and I got to go
back to when you know when I when when I
was a 22 year old kid sitting there
graduating from school I'm saying
there's this idea of that why do we wear
a short sleeve cotton t-shirt or summat
along state cotton t-shirt in the winter
no one had ever addressed it before and
my reaction was it was this white space
it said how come no one is making this
and so I went out and just went and took
some sheets of material made a couple
stretchy t-shirts out about my friends
and we created this whole new category
this to me was one of those moments it
was one of those moments that I look and
say I understand that there's here's the
next great device and here's jawboning
here's Fitbit
here's the new Apple watch is coming out
but no one had addressed what is
community and who synthesized that
information and making it easy and are
you getting out of your old category is
my question because Nike and Adidas was
who you were focused on and we just
heard from the adidas CEO they could
sign between five and five hundred
athletes yes well anyway you just chase
one another there's no strategy right
and we're not going to compete with our
dumbest competitor either so they will
they will chase the old they will chase
the old model and and we've got good
competitors in our space but we also see
some things that are a bit irrational
from the way we say so chasing and
bidding someone up is not the goal the
race to the bottom is not the goal that
we have so we think that in order to
spend our money you'll still see us go
after the right assets the appropriate
assets and we'll spend to get those
assets but then you also see us take a
different approach which we think this
is this is a different voice a different
communication a different handshake with
the Under Armour consumer but is adidas
your dumbest competitor specifically I I
don't mind you quoting me I didn't say
it but I don't like them no no I don't
like them I don't like the other guys
either but that's my job but are those
guys now your competition or is your
competition Google Apple I mean now
setting your site in the tech world
brother you're in a very different place
your background isn't technology it is
shirts and shoes you're a football
player not an app guy but let me give
you the good news is that we're not
competing with Apple we're not competing
with Samsung is that this is not Iowa
specific it's not Android specific we're
with everybody what I loved about
MapMyFitness when we bought these guys
back in December and what we learned was
that they were they were completely
agnostic we work with over 400 different
devices so whether you are jawbone or
Fitbit or Garmin or sinto whatever
device you have it will plug in and work
with the Under Armour Record platform
and it already works with MapMyFitness
or My Fitness Pal or endomondo this open
platform is where we are setting the
marks for our 120 million that added 4.2
million people new registrants in the
month of January alone in 31 days of
January we have one hundred and thirty
six thousand people every single day
signing up and joining our app I mean
this scale is extraordinary and do the
math on what that could be
extrapolate the numbers out we have the
largest athlete ik Fitness community in
the world today and it's only going to
get bigger you mentioned a race to the
bottom it makes me think of
conversations I've had with Mickey
Drexler
where he says that's what the retail
landscape is right now do you agree
I think it's tough I mean coming off a
Black Friday where you know competition
or discounting is the definition of
everything you know we're a full-price
brand we've always been a full-price
brand and our ambition is not to you
know sell at ten twenty or thirty off so
they're weighted at this point customers
are addicted to it well they are but we
haven't our customers not trained for
discount I think that's what happening
that's happening at retailer people are
getting trained to walking you know
unless you see 30 off 40 off and you're
walking by some of these retailers
Abercrombie and you see 50 off in the
door and saying how do you compete with
that so it makes us it helps us in it
reminds us why we need statement retail
it reminds us number one that we can
demonstrate for our accounts of what we
could look like how good we can look in
their stores and what how they should be
utilizing the under my brand but we are
not a discount brand we are we are a
technology company we are an innovation
company when you come to underarmor
you're not buying the basic dumb dumb
you know ten dollar t-shirt you're
buying you're spending money because it
is that good how about the challenges
you can't avoid the foreign-exchange
issues you face as the US dollar grows
stronger you're a victim what can you do
to protect yourself especially now that
you really care about the international
market with your endomondo acquisition
well it's it's one of the difficulties
we have with a company's about 9% of our
revenues outside the United States and
again our definition our goal that we
have as a company is to be a global
company which means that more than half
our reverence with some day come from
outside of our home country we're a ways
away from that happening frankly because
of the way the tax laws are set up we're
frankly disincentivize to do that
because we have to go find and create
international profits our effective tax
rate just a few years ago was over 42%
so when we look at it we think that a
we're driving global revenues and again
for a company that has you know Europe
lost across 130 million dollars for the
first time we opened our 57 store in
China this year you know really getting
behind in building a true global
business and our international business
was up 96 percent as a whole so we are
gonna be big and important on the global
stage and you know again we're just
getting started all right
congratulations Kevin Plank Thank You
Stephanie hopefully next time we sit
down I'll have beat you on record let's
do it let's do it